uh we are positively going to be windy
by the afternoon unfortunately
now i just want everybody to be prepared
for this right now we're pretty calm
light winds around the valley it's
really a nice thursday morning it is get
outside and enjoy go for the walk take
the dog out do whatever you need to do
this afternoon if you have an option to
be outdoors or not chances are you may
not want to be out in the wind if you
can avoid it 77 right now see the winds
are calm at the airport we're just
slightly warmer this morning than we
were yesterday at this hour sunrise 5 32
and sunset at 7 43 air still pretty dry
combination of dry air strong gusty
winds yes that elevates the fire weather
danger so fire weather warnings go into
effect today i'll show you more details
about that 71 in mesquite 68 in indian
springs valley in the mid to upper 60's
sandy valley rather warm at 75 77 in
laughlin 63 over in kingman and we've
got some cooler 50s up there in caliani
with 39 in ely 50 up there in tonepaw
gusty winds today turning cooler and
breezy though on friday so stronger
winds today into tonight and then breezy
to gusty at times through tomorrow but
those winds are going to change
direction and we are definitely going to
cool down a little bit hot temperatures
today though could see our first triple
digits of the year this afternoon then
followed by cooler 80s friday and
saturday so that's quite a change jet
stream tapping into some really cool air
now this trough of low pressure started
way up in the gulf of alaska so it's got
some cool air it's coming in you can see
the rain and snow into the pacific
northwest cold front is now in northern
nevada and as it gets closer to us when
it starts getting closer that's when the
stronger southwest winds pick up so this
afternoon into tonight is when we'll get
our strongest winds 30 to 35 miles an
hour then that cold front pushes through
late tonight early tomorrow morning and
the winds will turn direction out of the
northwest and they'll be out of the
north tomorrow temperatures will take a
dive it's going to be a big difference
fire weather warnings take effect before
noon all areas of southern nevada
include southern nye county and even
over into arizona through new mexico
into texas up into colorado i mean this
is elevated fire weather danger starts
at 11 a.m goes all the way until 8 pm
friday i mean this is this is a long
period of dry gusty conditions for us
102 uv index of 10
please hopefully you're using the
sunscreen if you're going to be out for
a while outside the hot sun look how we
dropped to the mid 80s friday and
saturday slowly getting back to some 90s
and even even low 90s again monday with
another little system that brings a
little bit of wind but next week it
looks like we do heat up again to 100
plus